bien repasemos brevemente lo que hemos
hecho en los vídeos pasados
supongamos que tengo una transformación
lineal de kepa de rn
rn
ahora yo sé que si usted es una
transformación lineal y trabajo con
coordenadas estándar entonces la imagen
de un vector x que está en coordenadas
estándar es igual a una matriz a
multiplicada por el vector x esto es
cierto si x está en coordenadas estándar
de hecho vamos a escribirlo en
coordenadas estándar
navas
estándar
lo que tenemos es que
tengo mi vector x entonces
multiplicar por la matriz
es lo mismo que aplicar la
transformación de
bueno pero qué pasa si no estamos
trabajando en las coordenadas estándar
nosotros sabemos ahora que rn tiene
múltiples bases así que supongamos que
ve
es una base de rn así que son n vectores
y realmente independientes b1 b2
ven son n vectores finalmente
independientes que están en rn y
entonces b
es una base
es una base de rn
entonces podríamos definir una matriz de
cambio a base c
qué consistía en simplemente una matriz
cuyas columnas eran precisamente los
vectores de mi base de 1
todos hasta
estas serán mis columnas
y decíamos que sí
la matriz
cambio
base
para la base para mí
entonces el vector x se podía
representar en coordenadas con respecto
a la base b
es decir aquí teníamos el vector x en
coordenadas respecto a la base b y la
imagen de x también podría ser
representada en coordenadas respecto a
la base b
podría tomar las coordenadas respecto a
la base de té de x
ahora en el vídeo pasado o en alguno de
los vídeos anteriores vimos qué
si tenía un vector
expresado en coordenadas respecto a la
base b y lo multiplicaba por la matriz
de cambio de base ce lo que obtenía era
precisamente el vector ha expresado en
la base estándar y si al contrario
empezaba con el vector en coordenadas
estándar entonces como se dice una
matriz invertible en nuestras
condiciones podría simplemente
multiplicar esta ecuación por sea la
menos 1 del pcc y obtener que el vector
a las coordenadas del vector
respecto a la base b eran iguales
eran iguales o son iguales hacia la
menos 1
por el vector en coordenadas estándar
así que volviendo a esta situación si yo
empiezo con el vector en coordenadas
respecto a la base b puedo multiplicar
por la matriz c y obtener el vector x y
si empiezo con las coordenadas estándar
de la imagen del vector x bajar la
transformación puedo multiplicar por ser
la menos 1 y obtener las coordenadas de
la imagen de x en la base b ahora bien
nosotros dijimos bueno esto es lo que
queremos entonces debe en vez de tener
que hacer todo este camino debe haber
una matriz que simplemente me envíe
directamente al vector x en coordenadas
respecto a la base ve a el vector de
coordenadas de su imagen bajo la
transformación en la base b es decir
aquí existe una matriz de que hacía
directamente este trámite por nosotros
y de hecho en el vídeo pasado dijimos
que d
de que llamamos la matriz asociada a la
transformación t
respecto a la base b era igual hacia la
menos 1
por a por c
a la matriz a la transformación t no le
interesan las coordenadas de nuestro
vector x
la transformación t siempre manda al
vector x al mismo punto ya sea que esté
en coordenadas estándar o en coordenadas
respecto a la base b entonces estos dos
vectores este sector y este vector son
simplemente expresiones del mismo vector
lo único que está cambiando es por así
decirlo el nombre que le estamos dando
uno es el nombre respecto a la base
estándar y otro es el nombre respecto a
la base b del mismo modo este vector y
este vector son exactamente el mismo
vector lo único que cambia es el nombre
o la forma de describir ese vector así
que esta fue la ecuación a la que
llegamos
ahora es también lógico preguntarse si
podemos hacer al revés
qué pasa si hubiéramos empezado con la
matriz de la transformación en términos
de la base bake qué pasa si
originalmente hubiéramos tenido de pues
entonces podríamos haber dicho lo
siguiente
desigual hacia la menos uno por porsche
entonces si yo multiplico
al menos uno de ambos lados
y multiplicó por la derecha por ser la
menos 1 entonces obtengo que la matriz
de por la matriz inversa de c debe ser
igual a la matriz inversa s por la
matriz
por la matriz inversa
este producto aquí es la matriz
identidad así que lo puedo quitar y
simplemente quedarme con
ah
sea la menos 1 por a
y si ahora multiplico
del lado izquierdo entonces obtengo ce
por de por ser al menos uno es igual
igual
por lo menos uno
qué es lo mismo que la matriz identidad
de nuestro es mi identidad
por la matriz a que simplemente sal así
que tengo que
es igual hace por de porsche a la menos
1 y esto es algo interesante porque
ahora podemos si tenemos la
transformación en términos de una base
obtener la matriz de la transformación
respecto a la base estándar
vamos a poner esto en práctica vamos a
hacer un ejemplo concreto
ya no vamos a trabajar en r2
así que voy a tener una transformación
lineal que va de r2
r2
y vamos a suponer que en términos de la
base estándar la imagen de un vector x
vector tdx está dado por el producto de
la matriz
3 - 2 2 - 2
el vector
así que en otras palabras esta matriz de
aquí
la matriz
ok supongamos que ahora me dan otra base
de r2 pongamos que ahora quiero trabajar
con la base de red o nada por el
conjunto
12 12 sector 12 y el vector 2 1
esa va a ser mi base nueva de r2 es muy
fácil ver que estos vectores son
linealmente independientes y que por lo
tanto son una base de r2 lo que quiero
hacer es escribir una matriz de
encontrar una matriz de tal que si la
multiplicó por el vector de las
coordenadas de un vector x respecto de
r2 obtengo las coordenadas respecto a la
base b de su imagen bajo la
transformación
de acuerdo con la fórmula que teníamos
de acuerdo con la fórmula de acá arriba
esta matriz de está dada por la inversa
de la matriz del cambio de base por la
matriz a por la matriz de cambio base
así que el primer paso es encontrar la
matriz de cambio de base y su inversa
para encontrar la matriz de cambio de
base es muy sencillo
la matriz de cambio de base s es
simplemente la matriz que tiene por
columnas a los vectores de mi base la
primera columna es el primer vector el
12 y la segunda es el segundo vector el
2 1
así que esa es mi matriz de cambio de
base
ahora para encontrar su inversa yo ya
tengo una fórmula para las inversas de
las matrices de 2 x 2 es uno entre el
determinante de c en determinante de la
matriz de cambio base
determinante la matriz de cambio base es
igual a 1 x 1 que es 1 - 2 x 2 x 41
menos 4 que es menos 3 así que la matriz
inversa es uno entre el determinante de
c
1 entre 3 x
intercambio los elementos en la diagonal
en este caso como son iguales se queda
igual la matriz y en los elementos fuera
de la diagonal les agrega un signo menos
esa es la inversa de mi matriz de cambio
de base
bien entonces ahora sólo me resta
aplicar la fórmula
d
es igual
la inversa en matriz de cambio de base
lo voy a poner en verde aquí
apenas un tercio
por la matriz
- 2
multiplicada por la matriz de azul de
acá
la presa aquí
es la
- 2
- todos
y eso multiplicada por la matriz de
cambio de base
multiplicada por la
y aquí hay que hacer toda la cuenta hay
que hacer todo este producto
primero vamos a trabajar con esta parte
del producto con el producto de estas
dos matrices la amarilla por la azul
esto de nuevo es una matriz de 2 x 2
su primera entrada la entrada 11 es la
primera fila por la primera columna 3
por 1 es 3 más menos 2 por 2 que sería
menos 43 menos 4 es menos 1
la entrada 12 sería primera fila por
segunda columna 3 por 12 6 más menos 2
por 1
6 - 24
la entrada 21 en segunda fila por
primera columna 2 por 12 más menos 2 por
24 menos 42 menos 4 es menos 2
-2 bien ahora han entrado 22 sería
segunda el segundo renglón por segunda
columna dos por dos es cuatro más menos
2 por 1 serie 4 minutos sería 2
positivos
muy bien ahora eso todavía no tengo que
multiplicar por
menos un tercio por la matriz
- 2 - 2
bien y esto cuánto me da
y vamos a hacer solo el producto de
matrices y lo voy a multiplicar un
tercio por ahí
el producto de estas dos matrices es de
nuevo en fer matriz de dos por dos
ninguna sorpresa y
primera fila por primera columna 1 por
menos 1 más menos 2 por menos 2 que
sería 4 positivo menos uno más 4
positivo es 3 positivo
la primera fila por segunda columna 1
por 4 es 4 menos dos por 12
4 - 4 más menos 4 0
segunda fila por primera columna menos
dos por menos uno es dos positivos uno
por menos dos esto es negativo
2 - 2 0
ok ahora segundo renglón segundo renglón
por segunda columna menos dos por cuatro
es menos ocho más dos por una que es 28
menos ocho más dos es menos seis y eso
lo tengo que multiplicar por menos un
tercio
ya esto me da el resultado que quiero
esta es la matriz d
menos un tercio por tres es menos 100
y menos un tercio por menos seis es dos
positivos y esta es la matriz de que
estoy buscando es decir esa matriz es
precisamente la que me convierte a un
vector en coordenadas respecto a la base
ve en su imagen bajo la transformación t
con respecto en coordenadas con respecto
a la base b
en el próximo vídeo veremos que esto
realmente funciona que esta matriz de la
matriz realmente hace lo que yo quiero
realmente convierte a los vectores de
esta forma